-Well, last night was
the New Hampshire primary,
and the people made their voic
loud and clear.
The voters say,
"We want Bernie Sanders
1% more than Pete Buttigieg.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The big winner in New Hampshir
was Bernie Sanders.
You can tell Bernie's fired up
Last night he was mixing
Metamucil into a shot of Jager
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Bernie was victorious,
and he celebrated apparently
with a closed-mouth smile
and a horn sound.
[ Mimics horn ]
Actually, Bernie
really was thrilled.
Here he is again
at his victory party.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Bernie hasn't been this excite
since movies got sound.
[ Laughter ]
Can we zoom in
on Bernie's grandson?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
He's thinking,
"I was pulling for my classmat
Pete Buttigieg."
[ Laughter ]
It was a big night
in New Hampshire.
Bernie Sanders finished first,
Pete Buttigieg finished second
and Joe Biden is finished.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Joe Biden finished the night
in a distant fifth place.
And now the four people ahead of
him are scared
because the last place you wan
Joe Biden is behind you.
And --
[ Laughter ]
Now, seriously --
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
You know. I know you know.
[ Applause ]
Seriously, I'm not saying
Biden's in trouble,
but in South Carolina
he's already losing
to a balanced broom.
[ Laughter ]
But Biden hasn't given up.
In fact, yesterday he said
Mickey Mouse could beat
President Trump in an election
Then Mickey heard and was like
"Actually at 91 years old,
I'm one of the youngest
Democrats in the race, so...
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Andrew Yang
officially dropped out
of the race.
Yang supported giving American
$1,000 a month,
reducing student loans,
and legalizing weed.
Americans heard that
and were like, "Wait, he did
We messed up.
Come back! Hey, we like you!
[ Laughter ]
Another candidate who looks like
their campaign is in rough shape
is Tom Steyer, which brings us
to a new piece called
"Tom Steyer,
Poor Choice of Words."
♪♪♪♪
-I think that we're gonna
come out of New Hampshire
and come to Nevada, where
in fact, I've already come
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa!
-Ow!
Dang.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
-Back in Washington, Trump was
bragging about the economy
and pointed out
that the big four companies,
Microsoft, Apple, Google,
and Amazon spell out "MAGA."
[ Laughter ]
Take a look, yeah.
And then cameras had to cut away
when Trump held up
four more companies --
Facebook, UPS,
Costco, and Kohl's.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
I saw that Crocs has teamed up
with KFC to make
new fried-chicken-inspired
clog shoes.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure if the word "clog
refers to the shoes
or your arteries.
But either way it's --
[ Laughter ]
And this is very exciting.
Chipotle just announced
a new promotion
where they're giving away
free guac.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take a look at this commercial
and see how it works.
-Good news, everyone.
Chipotle is now giving away free
guac to all rewards members.
Just text "guac mode" to 104836.
Not a rewards member?
That's cool.
Just visit our website and enter
your name, home address,
phone number, and e-mail,
then the first five digits o
your Social Security numbe
followed by the last four digits
of your Social Security number
Then all you have to do is
answer a few security questions.
Hang on. You're almost there
Then create a unique passwor
that's at least
42 characters long.
It should have upper and lower
case letters, along with numbers
and a few different types
of punctuation.
Next, submit a hair and saliva
DNA sample by mail,
and after six to eight month
of processing,
we should have the results
that confirm it's you.
Best of all, guac mode is only
available
at two participating
Chipotle restaurants,
and one is in Baku, Azerbaijan
Chipotle --
making dreams come true.
-Yeah, isn't that cool?
It's exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Free guac.
-Cool promotion.
-Yeah.
-Get this.
When a man at a restaurant
in Massachusetts
was paying a $12 bill, he left
the waitress a $2,000 tip.
[ Audience oohs ]
Then she was like,
"Fine, Mr. Bloomberg,
I'll vote for you."
[ Laughter ]
And finally I heard about
a Girl Scout troop
in Illinois that's been sellin
cookies outside of
a weed dispensary.
[ Laughter ]
They just earned a new badge
that says, "Friggin' genius.
We have a great show.